[Music]
if you remember Nora was puzzled over
how to find the instantaneous speed of
the ball she wanted to know the speed of
the ball at the instant it was at
position B in this video we will see
that the answer to this question gives
rise to one of the central idea of
calculus called differentiation and this
idea is built upon the idea of limits
that we discussed earlier anyway do you
remember the difficulty we faced in
finding the instantaneous speed if an
object is traveling with a constant
speed we can easily determine its speed
at any instant of time at every instant
this speed will be the same it will be
equal to the total distance traveled by
the ball divided by the total time taken
to cover that distance but we know that
in reality as we drop the ball its speed
keeps on increasing so in our case this
formula only tells us the average speed
of the ball if we blindly apply this
formula to find the instantaneous speed
at position B we will get the answer to
be zero over zero which doesn't make any
sense so how should we approach the
problem at the moment we only know how
to find the average speed of an object
so let's play around with this concept
and see if we can find any headway Nora
had earlier figured out the average
speed of the ball after it started its
motion and reached Midway at position B
it turns out to be 50 centimeters per
second now can you tell me what does
this average speed tell us it means that
on an average the speed of the ball is
50 as it travels this distance we could
think of it as a ballpark figure that
gives us an idea of the speed in this
duration now let me ask you an easy
question we know that the speed of the
ball in
is zero and we know that the average
speed in this time duration is fifty so
what can we tell about the instantaneous
speed of the ball at position B which of
these options will be correct
intuitively
we can say that it'll be greater than
fifty why so we know that as the ball
falls its speed keeps on increasing from
zero till it reaches the floor so for
some initial part it will be less than
the average speed hence after some point
the ball has to speed up and travel with
a speed greater than the average speed
hence its speed as it reaches point B
will definitely be greater than fifty to
understand this point you could look at
a set of horizontal bars like this with
increasing lens if I tell you that the
average length of these bars is fifty
and the length of the first bar is ten
then you'd be sure that the length of
the last bar will definitely be more
than fifty only then will you get the
average as 50 let's come back to a
problem now now let's say we find where
the ball is half a second after we drop
it the information we have is that it
covers a distance of 12 and 1/2
centimeters and reaches this position C
you could be wondering from where do we
get these values don't worry about them
for now ideally we can experimentally
determine them but we have calculated
them using some equation and for the
ease of calculation I have taken the
acceleration due to gravity to be 1
instead of 9.8 meters per second squared
now let's get back and calculate the
average speed of the ball between the
starting position a and C and also
between positions C and B here are the
formula for average speed can you
calculate these values the values turn
out to be 25 and 75 respectively
so now the picture is a little clearer
now the average speed between these two
points is 75 so what can we tell about
the ball speed at position B based on
the concept we saw earlier the ball
speed at B will actually be greater than
75 Wow
because we know that as the ball falls
its speed increases continuously so the
ball speed at B will be greater than at
C and therefore to cover this distance
in half a second
its speed will cross the average at some
point between B and C with the
information given we've concluded that
the instantaneous speed of the ball at B
will be definitely greater than 75 we
still haven't got the answer to the
instantaneous speed of the ball at
position B and how do we get that answer
for that let's ask ourselves a question
what happens after the ball crosses
position B it's obvious that at any
point below B the ball speed will be
greater than its speed at B and that
tells us something even more interesting
if we find the average speed between
position B and some point D below it we
will know that the instantaneous speed
at B will be less than this value so if
the average speed of the ball between B
and E is say 112.5 then we can say that
the instantaneous speed of the ball at B
will be definitely lesser than this
value what we trying to do here is get a
range we will continue this in the next
part
our goal is to find the instantaneous
speed at B and we know that it's greater
than 75 now we are given some more
information about what happens after the
ball crosses position B at time T equals
one point two five seconds the ball is
that the position D which is twenty
eight point one two five centimeters
below position B now let's find the
average speed between B and D can you
try it it turns out to be one hundred
and twelve point five and what does this
tell us
as we saw before it means the
instantaneous speed of the ball at B
will be definitely less than this value
so we get the speed of the ball at B to
be somewhere between 75 and 100 12.5
we're getting closer to the answer of
finding the instantaneous speed of the
ball at position B it will be between
these two numbers let's proceed further
and find the average speed of the ball
between point B and points closer to it
we are given some more information here
we see that the ball is at positions E
and F at zero point nine five seconds
and one point zero five seconds
respectively let's try calculating the
average speed in these two regions the
calculations gives us these two values
97.5 and 102.5
the instantaneous speed at B will be
between these two values now we see that
we have an even better estimate of the
instantaneous speed at VZ did you get
the idea what should be our next step
that's right we should find the average
speed values between points B and the
positions closer to B so as we calculate
the average speed values closer and
closer to position B we get closer to
the actual speed of the ball at B we see
that these numbers approach the number
100 from the top as well as from the
bottom if we continue to calculate the
average speed in even smaller intervals
we will get even closer to the number
100 so we can conclude that the
instantaneous speed of the ball at B
would be hundred centimeters per second
this is the basic idea we get closer and
closer to the answers with this approach
we see that the average speed approaches
a number which will be the speed of the
ball at position B this process is
called the limit process we say that in
the limit this time interval gets closer
and closer to zero the average speed of
the ball approaches the instantaneous
speed of the ball Norah's problem is now
result she knows a way to find the
instantaneous speed of an object she
realizes that understanding calculus is
easy it's just our knowledge of algebra
stretched to a limit now let me tell you
that this is the basic idea on which the
concept of default solution is based
what do we mean by it the speed of an
object measures how its position changes
with respect to time it's nothing
but the rate of change of the position
of the object what we did here near
Point B is that we looked at how the
position of the ball changes in very
very small time intervals and then we
found the instantaneous speed of the
ball at B the process by which we found
this rate of change at an instant is
called differentiation we will see that
the differentiation helps us in
analyzing how things change using the
concept we can't find the instantaneous
rate of change of any quantity we will
learn more about it in our upcoming
videos in the next video we will further
explore this idea and see how it's
related to another problem we discussed
earlier which was about finding the
areas of shapes
[Music]